as a kid there was a part of the flash
museum that always scared me
I guess it's normal for children to be
afraid of monsters but this monster was
different
everybody is Charlie this is gonna be my
flash episode 3 video many apologies to
Benedict Cumberbatch for slandering his
name so many times during the episode
with this new Sherlock Wells we learned
all kinds of cool details about how
cicadas dagger works the other powers
that it gives him and got some more
mysteries about what's happening in the
future where Nora comes from there even
a couple really cool reverse-flash
Easter eggs in here too you guys may
have spotted some familiar plot twists
and tropes from earlier seasons careful
for spoilers if you have not seen the
episode yet there's a new round to that
flash ring giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
flash related comment on the video so
top-10 and easter eggs here we go
starting with number 10 we got our first
official look at the flash Museum I
didn't expect to have it this soon and
what is the first thing that Nora sees
when she walks in there reverse flashes
suit with the Tachyon enhancer on it so
just remember that it's a recurring
theme through the episode reverse-flash
Easter eggs and tropes they put the
thinker display here you see a lot of
the common rows you see the axel
trickster costume you see zooms costume
dr. lights costume even sabotage costume
over here a lot of these other costumes
are from season what like you have heat
waves gun pipe Piper's gauntlets the
iron mask that jay garrick was forced to
wear by zoom during season two so number
9 they need a little bit of help from
Sherlock wells they bring back air wells
from the Council of wells there's this
big running joke about how he hated
Cisco and Harrison wells from earth-2
but he apparently loves Barry Allen and
his family and introduces us to the new
version of wells we're gonna have this
season of course they drop a benedict
cumberbatch sherlock reference they do
prove during the episode that he can be
a good detective but he winds up being
super shady and as a consequence of the
things that they do to try and get his
help it seems like they're setting stuff
up to pay off a later in the season or
maybe future story arcs like Barry needs
to make a whole bunch of money really
fast so he sells off shares in STAR Labs
meaning that now somebody else who
bought those will have a controlling
interest in STAR Labs that could wind up
being a character
they pay off later this season remember
it's gonna be three different story arts
so a lot of stuff they set up now might
not be paid off till the back half of
the season he also lets us know that
iris had a tattoo of Eddie on her
shoulder
he says former lover but I'm just
assuming that was Eddie because we
haven't seen iris with any other dude
ever in the history of the show and
apparently there are 14 million people
living in Central City that is the
biggest city in the United States just
for reference there's a little over 8
million people living in New York City
number 8 we get a scene with Kaitlyn's
mother who is just as cold as ever make
as many ice puns as you want anytime
anything is happening with Kaitlyn and a
scene the good thing about this I think
though is that Kaitlyn is aware of
what's going on while it's happening she
knows about her mother's deception so
it's just set up for her detective work
later on so it's almost like all the
characters and all their storylines are
doing detective work which is probably
the reason why this version of Welles is
named Sherlock Wells just because it's a
very detective CSI based season which
was the whole lesson that they learned
at the end of the episode like Nora said
we have to take him down without using
our powers number 7 big one the flash TV
show officially changes comic books
cicadas origin story on the TV shows
they go after David Hirsh he does have
all the kinds of fake traps and bombs so
he clearly is kind of shady but they
learned that he's not the cicada that
they've been going after but the thing
is is that comic book cicadas name is
David Hirsch so when Sherlock wells
tells them this is your man he's not
lying because 37 other times it was
David Hirsch who became cicada
eventually we learned that TV show
cicadas real name is Orlan which is
actually the name of a Green Lantern
Corps character I don't think that
they're trying to imply anything there
they just want to give him a different
name and it's a little bit of an easter
egg for Green Lantern stuff but that's
just the TV show writers saying oh this
is going to be completely different
because of what Nora did to change the
timeline
they say that cicada wasn't supposed to
become cicada till much later in the
timeline so what does that sound like
that sounds like Barry becoming the
flash earlier in season 1 that he was
originally supposed to become the flash
because reverse flash needed that to
happen faster so that he could get back
to the future so just remember that
reverse flash
of accelerating certain things in the
timeline we'll come back to that later
on my list here five elongated man and
Caitlyn break into her mother's lap they
had that funny resident evil' lasergrid
Easter egg they used this as a way to
sort of set up Caitlyn's relationship
with her father and provide more context
she has all these happy memories of him
when she was a child he was a scientist
who is obsessive-compulsive a little bit
like she is her mother implied that that
kind of led to his downfall and eventual
death
so we'll talk about this more as we get
more clues for what's going on with him
but clearly I think the idea is is they
want you to know that Caitlyn really
loves him and that she might be forced
to choose between him and team flash at
some point she might care about him but
what if he winds up being a villain
later on it's sort of a better version
of what they did with her during season
three when she cited with sabot our over
team flash because she had this
connection to a version of Barry but she
was kind of evil so she was giving in to
that number four cicada going after Joe
and Cecile to try and lay that trap for
Cisco the cool thing about this moment
is is that Joe West even though he's
sitting down again in a scene knows
exactly what's going on he's not really
susceptible to the torture the cicada is
trying to visit on him they want to let
you know that he knows what's going on
he knows how to handle this but Cecile
is not and she's like freaking out about
their baby and her powers are still on
the fritz so she's the one that flips
her because cicada implies that
he's going to kill their family just to
try and get at Cisco Cisco comes rushing
in just like Barry said Nora should not
do so they're trying to show you the
consequences of what happens when you
drink in superhero and don't think about
what you're doing three Nora's planned
to save Cisco by faking his death so she
learns the lesson that Barry gave her so
the I mean they're trying to pay that
off relatively quickly she's still
probably gonna make a whole bunch of
mistakes this season but they just want
to show you that she does learn pretty
quickly she's intelligent so she comes
up with that plan relatively quickly in
that flash time moment when she slows
everything down we also learn about a
whole bunch of new abilities the cicadas
dagger gives him it gives him the
ability to fly and he's able to force
grab Cisco by throwing it into his back
then calling it back to himself
so you see Cisco fly across the screen
very cool practical effect the flying
was
actually more surprising I'm just like
how many more abilities is gonna have he
even uses the dagger to create an energy
shield during that explosion so I
wouldn't be surprised that there are
even more abilities that it has that we
learn about in future episodes but
here's the thing though later in the
episode when he's visiting his daughter
in the hospital we see he has this
really weird-looking Dark Matter wound
on him that probably has something to do
with how the dagger was created in how
he has this connection to it so I'm
assuming that he's so obsessed with
getting rid of metas like he says his
work isn't done by the end of the season
that will wind up warping him so much
that he looks way crazier and much more
like what you would think a comic book
villain would look like to was Caitlin's
detective montage at the end like I said
everybody this season gets to be a
little bit of a detective so she uses
her childhood periodic table that she
made up to decode the message from her
father
and it's basically him trying to get her
to find him we don't know why and then
it seems like someone's watching her on
the monitors I'm assuming that that
person is Sherlock wells because of the
way he sort of lurked on Nora at the end
of the episode he seems a little bit
creepy but I think that he's are
supposed to be a very observant person
and point out really shady stuff when he
sees it like number one pointing out the
Nora probably didn't come up with the
idea to change the timeline by
destroying the satellite therefore
creating the cicada problem this season
all by herself
somebody probably told her to do that
you should go back and change this so
another possible reverse-flash theory is
that he is in the future manipulating
Nora's love for her father by giving her
all these ideas that will cause her to
change the timeline in a way that will
benefit him later on because if anybody
knows how to manipulate the timeline for
their own benefit it's reverse-flash
but next week we get to see her
Throwdown with Barry something is very
clearly poisoned her I don't know if
it's gonna be negative Speed Force or
something crazy like that but very
clearly they're hyping up a flash verse
flash battle at the stadium as an homage
to reverse-flash and Barry back from
season 1 when they were running around
the stadium flying at each other so
again one more big reverse flash Easter
Egg so you can kind of see how they're
peppering him in the background before
hopefully later the season we get to see
his new face congratulations to Mel
golden
you're the giveaway winner from my last
big DC video please email me on the
about page of my channel so I can get
your details I'll post my flash trailer
for episode 4 tomorrow
click here for the new Iron Man Avengers
4 armored teaser and click here for my
arrow episode in a another preview of
the crossover with Stephen Amell and
John Wesley Shipp thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]